deswegen bin ich nach drei Jahren Leben
in der Großstadt genauer gesagt in Köln
wieder zurück in mein Heimatdorf gezogen
als ich 19 Jahre alt war bin ich von
hier nach Köln gezogen ich wollte da
immerhin war so die medien-hauptstadt
ich habe das studiert und weiter meine
Youtube Videos gedreht und für mich war
es echt ein Traum dahin zu ziehen ich
habe super viele Leute kennengelernt die
ähnliche Sachen machen wie ich wir waren
unter der Woche abends mal los feiern
und sonst der Brief ist Häuser heute
gestern war Karneval nach eineinhalb
Jahren habe ich dann aber gemerkt dass
mich Köln total Stress die ganzen
Menschen auf einem Haufen ich bin
morgens immer durch diesen mega Verkehr
zur Uni gefahren dann wieder zurück habe
noch irgendwas gefilmt und ich kam
einfach gar nicht mehr klar irgendwann
von dem einen auf den anderen Tag habe
ich dann entschlossen wieder
zurückzuziehen hat meine Sachen
zusammengepackt bin hierhin gezogen die
habe ich jetzt eine riesen Wohnung ein
ziemlich großes Büro und ich gebe viel
weniger aus als in Köln und ich bin
tausendmal weniger gestresst ich weiß
vielleicht bin ich auch eine Ausnahme
aber ihr könnt ja mal schreiben wie es
Euch so geht